et on reste à Tours le stationnement
gratuit des véhicules électriques c'est
fini à partir du 1er juillet la mesure
avait été votée en 2019 pour encourager
les tours en jouant à rouler plus propre
plus globalement c'est toute la
politique du stationnement qui est revue
on en parle avec mon invité ce soir on
sort Christophe boulanger bonsoir vous
êtes donc conseillers municipal de Tours
notamment en charge des questions de
mobilité d'abord sur les voitures
électriques le stationnement gratuit
avec adopté par la précédente
municipalité confirmée donc par la vôtre
dans quatre mois c'est terminé pourquoi
de nouveau faire payer le parking au
propriétaire de voiture propre voilà la
raison est assez simple c'est une bonne
mesure mais en 2019 on avait très peu de
voitures électriques il y avait besoin
de créer une dynamique pour que les gens
s'approprient ce nouveau mode de
déplacement et donc c'est une mesure
incitative qui a plutôt bien fonctionné
mais qui a trop bien fonctionné alors
trop bien c'est à dire véhicule
électrique aujourd'hui on identifie sur
les derniers chiffres qu'on avait en fin
d'année dernière au moment où on a pris
la décision parce que c'est une décision
qui a été prise en fin
[Musique]
puisse y venir à partir du moment où on
stationne gratuitement sur des places à
longueur de journée
les voitures les plus polluantes des
agglomérations d'ici 2025 ce profil
justement alors la ZFE c'est un sujet
qui convient de construire avec la
métropole puisque ça va être métropole
que chef de fil de ce dossier on ne sait
pas encore effectivement quels seront
les conditions de la mise en place quel
sera le périmètre de la mise en place
mais c'est pas c'est pas
le véhicules électriques c'est critères
0 par exemple ces critères 0 mais il y a
d'autres véhicules qui seront qui seront
autorisés sur le territoire ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'en fait le véhicule
électrique c'est pas la peine c'est pas
la panacée d'abord pour une raison
simple c'est que le véhicule électrique
en fait c'est une forme d'exportation de
la pollution puisqu'on ne pollue
ailleurs pour être propre chez soi quand
on en a les moyens donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est qui est
intéressant mais qui est pas qui est pas
qui est pas la solution
et l'autre problème c'est que le sujet
c'est aussi un sujet de l'occupation de
l'espace public et que ça ne ça ne
génère pas des pratiques nouvelles en
particulier ça ne permet pas de lutter
contre l'auto-solisme alors justement
vous parlez de l'embolisation des places
de parking vous allez les rendre plus
cher en surface et moins cher sur les
parkings souterrains c'est ça alors on a
décidé déjà puisque puisque c'est
effectivement janvier 2023 les parkings
souterrains du cœur métro du cœur
métropolitain et du coeur de chœur de la
ville de Tours ont baissé de 30% sur
leur premier heure depuis le 1er janvier
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est passé
de 2,40 la première heure au parking de
la gare par exemple à 1 euro un euro 70
on a baissé les parkings en ouvrage de
de 30% pourquoi parce que on a
collectivité a investi dans des ouvrages
qui coûtent extrêmement cher et
aujourd'hui un ato de remplissage qui
est de l'ordre de 30%. c'est juste une
ineptie que de ne pas saturer des
ouvrages qui ont coûté cher à la
collectivité quand on sait que tout le
monde veut accéder à l'espace public en
surface on a les commerçants qui
demandent des terrasses pour pour
déjeuner tranquillement dehors quand il
fait beau on a des citoyens moins cher
dans ce terrain c'est ça moi cher en
souterrain et de l'ordre de combien
c'est c'est en place depuis le 1er
janvier 23 et c'est ça sera sur la durée
de la DSP qui a été renouveler pendant 6
ans et on réajuste les tarifs en ouvrage
qui était très peu cher par rapport aux
autres métropoles la plupart des
métropoles étaient entre 2 euros et 2,50
€. nous on était pour le tarif rouge à
1,90 on le porte à 2 euros ce qui fait
une augmentation de 10% alors que sur la
période 2018-2024 puisque c'est arrivé
date de 2018 l'inflation est de l'ordre
de 15%. est-ce que vous allez aussi
est-ce que vous allez supprimer des
places de parking en surface à la suite
de cette mesure alors l'autre mesure
c'est quand on va passer de une deux
trois zones à Deux zones pour simplifier
et qui est beaucoup plus de lisibilité
dans dans l'occupation
du domaine public et puis il va y avoir
des places qui vont être supprimées mais
parce que il y a besoin justement ça va
permettre de gagner de l'espace en
remplissant les parkings souterrains
combien de place sont peut-être
supprimés là ce que vous avez envie
c'est difficile à dire c'est 4 dernières
années on a on a supprimé 10% des places
payantes mais la majorité la moitié pour
la majorité précédente la moitié pour
les nôtres l'aménagement du haut de
l'avenue Gramont l'aménagement de la
place Châteauneuf pour la majorité
précédente la place du grand marché et
puis et puis l'avenue la rue Buffon pour
pour notre pour notre équipe municipale
donc c'est une tendance qui qui fait que
il y a besoin de se rapproprier et on on
poursuit cette logique merci beaucoup
Christophe boulanger conseil municipal
de Tours merci beaucoup d'être venu ce
soir si votre plateau